English actor comedian screenwriter
producer and notorious prankster Sacha
Baron Cohen is known for pushing the
envelope with his original characters
from British suburban rapper Ali G to
Kazakhstan II journalist Bora Cohen's
antics have established him as a
household name but we haven't heard much
from the controversial actor lately
which makes us wonder why won't
Hollywood cast Sacha Baron Cohen anymore
retired characters aside from a
promotional appearance on Jimmy Kimmel
Live in 2015
Borat hasn't shown up much since 2008
Austrian fashion reporter Bruno and
admiral general aladeen have all but
disappeared as well the humor of Cohen's
films came from fooling unsuspecting
victims which is almost impossible to
accomplish these days in an interview
with The Daily Mail Cohen explained
every new person who sees the movie is
one less person I can be Borat or Bruno
with again so finishing a movie means
having to say goodbye Ali G still shows
up every so often though most recently
he was a presenter at the 2016 Academy
Awards Cohen explained that the Academy
wanted him to present as himself so we
had to sneak his costume in but my thing
was I knew that they would be trying to
see without smoke or anything end so my
wife very kindly smuggled the beard in
her underwear too risky Cohen's brand of
humor is admittedly not for everyone for
an episode of - Ali G show he dressed up
as Borat and led an anti-semitic
sing-along in a bar in Arizona
Cohen received a number of complaints
about the incident the anti-defamation
league even wrote to him saying we are
concerned that the irony may have been
lost on some of your audience in
attempting to expose bigotry and
Prejudice you also bear a responsibility
to be sensitive but society has changed
since Borat hit theatres in 2006 in an
interview with The Telegraph Cohen
admitted that he didn't think his films
would get made if he pitched them today
as studios would rather make a profit
than take a risk disruptive and
destructive in September 2008 Cohen as
flamboyant fashion reporter Bruno
crashed in Milan Fashion Week he used
fake passes to get backstage at a Nagata
Ruiz de la prada show and wore a suit
made entirely of veldt
he even managed to get on the catwalk
which he strutted down with a variety of
costumes stuck to his body eventually
the lights went out he was removed by
security and had to explain himself to
the Italian police a spokeswoman for the
National Chamber of Italian fashion told
The Telegraph that while Cohen's stunt
gave her a good laugh some people were
very angry and annoyed however many of
Colin's victims have moved past anger
and into lawsuits in an interview with
today Cohen joked that he thinks he
holds the Guinness World Record for most
sued actor in history the executive
director of desert Valley charities
tried to sue the Bruno crew claiming
that one of Cohen's pranks left her
confined to a wheelchair a Palestinian
grocer who is portrayed in Bruno as a
terrorist settled a slander suit against
both Cohen and David Letterman for
defamation of character to South
Carolina college students a Baltimore
driving instructor a Macedonian singer
and the remaining village of glod have
all tried to sue the man behind bora
bora also ended up offending the entire
country of Kazakhstan with its backwards
and bigoted portrayal but former deputy
foreign minister ricotta Liev seems to
have realized that all publicity is good
publicity as he invited Cohen to
Kazakhstan saying that he wanted to show
Borat that women drive cars wine is made
of grapes and Jews are free to go to
synagogues too offensive while one might
assume Cohen isn't concerned with
political correctness that's far from
the truth there's that one Mexican
chairpeople to me Moore has stalks him
in her house yeah if you sit here if you
can even believe it plenty of his jokes
have ended up on the cutting room floor
May 11 is the best
[Music]
Cohen told The Telegraph that he and his
riders will always stop to discuss
whether they're going too far with any
of their jokes saying there are a lot of
jokes that I wouldn't make I'm
continually filtering stuff that's too
much but today as society has become
more inclined to speak out against the
offensive and the insensitive Cohen's
job has only become more difficult
he says comedy is a weird thing that's
hard to analyze I worked very hard to
make these films I want the movie to be
as good as possible sometimes they work
and sometimes they don't he bailed on
Queen in 2013 Cohen was set to play
Freddie Mercury in an official biopic
sanctioned by the surviving members of
the band Queen but when creative
differences arose : called it quits in
an interview with Howard Stern Cohen
talked about Queens lead guitarist who
was also the lead producer of the film
saying Brian May is an amazing musician
but he's not a great movie producer they
are a band they want to protect their
legacy as a band they want it to be
about Queen and I I fully understand in
an interview of his own may was less
polite saying we had some nice times
with Sasha kicking around ideas but he
went off and told untruths about what
happened it's obvious that it wasn't
going to work him playing Freddie it
wouldn't suspend your disbelief
diminishing returns since Cohen's
breakout hit Borat each of his
subsequent films made less money than
the one before his latest film the
brothers Grimsby was a flop with an
opening weekend gross of only 3.2
million dollars Sony's former
distribution chief
Rory Brewer told variety we certainly
wanted more sasha is amazing and we love
him and we tried to crack the code on it
but it just didn't happen for us
however Cohen is still developing his
own films in 2016 he was attached to an
American remake of clown a Danish comedy
as well as a film adaptation of the
classic comic strip Mandrake the
Magician will he really be able to work
his magic and get back in the spotlight
time will tell thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]